[Music]
Cameron this is Tyson calling you out
for the Beckford bootcamp come on buddy
I'm waiting on you
let's go mmm oh man that is world-famous
fashion model Titan Beckford calling out
Cameron with Tyson you know what you
didn't know that this man was locked and
loaded and ready for the gun show there
was a little prep going into this one
I'm not going to lie there may have even
been a spray tan breakdown I can't say
for sure listen all week long we have
pushed camera to show us to show the
world that he can complete superhuman
feat where could he go mano-a-mano with
some of the most famous male dancers in
the world can cam become a chip and Dam
[Applause]
what's the craziest fan experience that
you've had here at Chippendales probably
the underwear we have a little box back
there or underwear trick is that they
troll that's masdea they take their
underwear off in the audience tonight
I've had two but one wanted her
underwear back at the end of show side
have you ever dated one since have you
ever gone out of days I don't a date
date but we've gone to the we have this
thing called the floor lounge where we
go back there we'll have drinks with it
last night I got my butt grab a few
times a while back is about Mariah Carey
reporter Carrie yeah no it was before I
got a kick out of it she give you a bus
to give you a tip very like you got $300
is the tip of excuse that could take the
boys out for three so Chippendales isn't
just about getting up close to Mariah or
being shirtless man candy there are
rules you got to rehearse up to four
hours a day but most important is the
six rule all Chippendales must be at
least six feet tall and have a six-pack
so an eight pack is always good too
so was i up for this cam-cam challenge
Dyson hooks me up and put me through his
Beckford bootcamp lesson number one how
to do the shirt rip here we go grab
right here always put totally wrong you
got to go down
oh go so that was a bit of a fail uh
yeah can I get another shirt yeah
official place you go yeah it's working
together alright wait wait where is
there you go I'm a little excited Tyson
I know you are we will make you a chip
of dill yeah yeah you know what you know
what would help me a little bit what's
up if we all kind of do it together if
you want to do that one number almost
and Counting count three two one yeah
lesson two and workout before we turn it
out on stage we all like to workout
right before it shows okay good whoa
the Chippendales usually do this one
hour before showtime
the purpose so all those muscles are
pumping then I put my clothes back on
the show begins
and Tyson puts me to the test oh this
isn't my moment of pet flexing shirt
ripping truth
[Applause]
finally the encore and then might be
rule Mannie Drennen was pumping right
all right yes you did
whoa well it's Todd now you graduated my
brother really yeah the butyne cuz you
come on ma official my wake up where
like that yes you will camp can yeah oh
[Music]
that's it come put my shirt on that dumb
oh yeah now is it weird that I still
have the bowtie and cuff like sort of as
a prize back in my own is it weird that
I want to see them wear those but I
thought to be a little bit too much
maybe just maybe now you can still see
the man himself sizes Beckford hosting
the Chippendales show it's a real hotel
in Las Vegas through July 9th you don't
want to miss this
you